إن أدوار المصممين خلال هذا الوباء
هي أنه من المهم حقًا أن نجعل من
الحل يمكنك المساعدة كلما
فعلنا ما في وسعنا ، هناك مسؤولية
لتصميم عالم أفضل
[موسيقى]
أحد الأشياء الأكثر إثارة للإعجاب
هو ببساطة تنوعها  فقط
فيما يتعلق بالثقافة والجنسية ولكن
فيما يتعلق بنوع المشاكل
التي يستجيبون لها للأطفال
في سن الثانية يميلون إلى أن يكونوا فضوليين حقًا ،
فكرنا كيف يمكننا فعلاً جعلهم
يرغبون في غسل أيديهم.
وهناك
مثل المفاجأة التي تحتها
الماء والصابون أحد أفضل الوسائل
لمحاربة انتشار الفيروسات ، إنه
مشروع بسيط ولكن له
آثار كبيرة وسيكون
مثل بلد ما إذا كان بإمكاننا المساعدة بأي
شكل من الأشكال.  يُطلق على المثير حقًا اسم
ممرضة البخار والتي يجب أن أقول إنها تتمتع
بإمكانيات هائلة حقًا ، ونرى أن
الممرضة والعاملين في المجال الطبي
لم يشعروا بالأمان في وظائفهم التي
يتعرضون لها طوال الوقت  نحن اعتقدنا هذه
المشكلة ونجعل ممرضة البخار
مشروع للأشخاص لذا نريد أن نرى
قلة من الممرضات تساعد الناس
واحدة من مشكلة أن شخصًا مصابًا
بفيروس كورونا هي الطريقة اليومية
لشراء سائل بريطاني كل ما تحتاجه هو
تعمل تقنية الزبدة الإلكترونية على تحويل الماء
على الملح والناخبين إلى
ماء التبييض يمكنك الحصول على مائة لتر
من السائل
[موسيقى]
يمكنك نشر رسالة صحية على
منصتنا وسيرى الآخرون هذه
الرسالة ويحاولون الاتصال بك
ومساعدة الجميع  أنواع من الأشخاص وخاصة
الأشخاص الضعفاء ، يأتي الإلهام
من القصص التي حدثت بالفعل
للجدة الذين تبرعت
بأعضاء الفريق الطبي لمدخرات حياتهم
لطلب الدعم لأوهان ، نريد أن نكون
منصة حيث يمكن للجميع طلب المساعدة
والحصول على استجابة سريعة في كثير من الأحيان
ما تراه من المشروع هو
إلحاح شخصي عميق لحل مشكلة
أعيشها مع أجدادي ولم
أستطع حتى أن أتخيل كيف
سيكون الأمر إذا  كان علي أن أكون في
الموقف أو إذا كانوا سيموتون بمفردهم
في سرير المستشفى دون وجود عائلاتهم ،
لذلك اعتقدنا أن هذا
يمكن أن يساعد في التغلب على الموقف
وبطريقة أكثر إنسانية أعتقد أنه إذا كان بإمكاننا
توفير هذا الحل
للأشخاص  أن نكون متعاونين للغاية وسنكون
فخورين جدًا بذلك ، لذلك كانت
تجربة مطمئنة وملهمة حقًا
أن نرى أنه حتى في ظل هذا النوع من الوقت
غير المؤكد للغاية والنوع المخيف ،
هناك الكثير من الإمكانات
والخيال والذكاء
المتاحين في جميع أنحاء العالم